liebe Zuschauer sie haben es gehört zur
Stunde läuft in Manhattan im
bezirksstrafgericht die Verlegung der
Anklage Johannes Hano der Kollege vor
Ort hat gesagt möglicherweise gibt es
gleich ein Statement von Donald Trump
wir haben das Live Signal aus dem Foyer
aus Manhattan hier vorliegen sobald es
dort irgendwas geht wer mir das
selbstverständlich live übertragen
Android Dennison der
Politikwissenschaftler aus Wyoming mit
Sitz in Königswinter ist nach wie vor
bei uns im Studio ja das ist ja jetzt
ein spannender Moment auf mafi gesamte
Öffentlichkeit vor allem in den USA aber
auch darüber hinaus schauen wir mal wie
es könnte zwar nicht dabei sein aber sie
haben Erfahrung auch mit solchen
Prozessen in der Beobachtung von solchen
Prozessen was wird da jetzt passieren im
Gerichtssaal
ja also die meisten in Wyoming denn kein
anderer Bundesstaat hat eine höhere
Prozentzahl für Trump gestimmt als
Wyoming die würden sagen dass es ein
politisches Theater dass das was da im
Gerichtssaal stattfindet ist er hat
nichts mit Amerika und mit
Rechtsstaatlichkeit zu tun auf der
anderen Seite die Leute die meinen
Amerikas Rechtssystem funktioniert gut
die werden erwarten dass Trump erstmal
in Gewahrsam genommen wird der wird dann
die Prozeduren durchgehen und dann wird
er die klagsche zuhören müssen und dann
wird schwarz auf weiß stehen was was mit
ähm mit seiner Zukunft passieren könnte
und dann gibt es die Möglichkeit das
eine Rechtsanwälte auch bestimmte Sachen
in Frage stellen sie beobachten ja
Donald Trump seine Karriere als
Unternehmer als Politiker als Präsident
und jetzt als Ex-Präsident schon lange
was wird mit ihm machen wenn er da auf
der Anklagebank sitzt und die mutmaßlich
30 Anklage Punkte vorgelesen bekommt wer
den das Kratzen oder wird in das
tangieren oder Gerät geht er gleich da
raus und sagt hey hier bin ich in dem
Kampf an so wie man den immer kennt man
fragt sich schon was sind trumpscup in
Trumps kopflos geht aber wir haben schon
im Bild gesehen als er aus Trump Tower
gelaufen ist hatte eingebaute fist hoch
geballte Faust hochgehalten und während
der Fahrt zur Gerichtssaal hat er noch
mal auf seinen soziales Medien gesagt
hatte es ist zu Real ich werde
festgenommen ich kann nicht glauben dass
das in Amerika passiert also eine
gewisse anhetzung es ist möglich dass im
Gerichtssaal der Richter auch sagt jetzt
wir haben ihn mit viel Würde behandelt
aber bisschen aufpassen mit diese
Botschaft dass er ihr unterstütze jetzt
zu Gewalt greifen sollten oder sowas
denn ein Richter kann auch Donald Trump
sagen sie haben jetzt eine
Schweigepflicht das wird dann eine ganze
Prozess und minimieren Herr Trump wenn
sie ständig ihr Folge aufrufen hier zu
Gewalt zu greifen also solche Sachen
sind auch möglich in ein
Gerichtsverfahren kann auch sein wird
nicht mit Tomte der Fall sein aber bei
einer der Flucht vielleicht gefürchtet
ist dann würde auch ein ein Geld erstmal
ausbezahlt werden muss
genau Fluchtgefahr besteht ja das werden
wir alles im Laufe des Abends erfahren
wie das da im Gerichtssaal über die
Bühne gegangen ist fünf Fotografen
dürfen dabei sein vermutlich wird es
dann im Laufe des Abends dann auch Fotos
gehen geben vielleicht noch einen Satz
zum Richters Juan mehr kann okay er ist
der Richter bei diesem Verfahren wie
wichtig was muss man über ihn wissen und
wie wichtig ist es dass das alles darf
über die Bühne geht nämlich nach
rechtsstaatlichen Kriterien
unheimlich wichtig wichtig denn
natürlich Trump seinen Rechtsanwälte und
all seine unterstütze in Amerika
behaupten von Anfang an dass es nicht
richtig vorgeht und da darf man dann
keinen Verdacht erwecken dass etwas
schiefgeht diese Richter ist da für
bekannt dass er auch ein politisches
Gefühl hat für was was dazu gehört wir
haben auch gesehen da muss so haben wir
gehört nicht in Handschellen erscheinen
also die würde dieses Abends ein
bisschen respektieren gibt aber diese
Richter auch mehr Macht nachher wenn
trumpet Probleme macht jetzt geht's ja
interessanterweise für die eine Seite
darum ähm also für die Demokraten dass
sie sagen niemand steht über dem Gesetz
nicht auch nicht der Präsident der
Vereinigten Staaten das ist trotzdem das
erste Verfahren das erste Mal dass ein
ehemaliger Präsident angeklagt wird und
die andere sagt Seite sagt es ist eine
Hetzjagd eine hexenjagdkrank selber sagt
ist das ganze Verfahren dann jetzt dazu
geeignet die Gräben die entstanden sind
und die bestehen zwischen beiden Lagern
noch weiter zu vertiefen
auf jeden Fall haben wir gesehen dass
die Unterstützung für Donald Trump ist
stärker geworden und auch lauthaltiger
in der Vorwurf das amerikanische
Rechtssystem wird von den Linken
instrumentalisiert dass das können wir
sehen Trump wird auch
sehr oft im gerichtssa sein und das
sorgt immer für Schlagzeilen wie das
abläuft Amerikaner lieben
gerichtsdramen und werden da sicher
zuschauen und uns sehr viel darüber
spekulieren aber es kann auch sein dass
Trump nach einer Weile auch in seinen
neuesten Umwandlung von Theater machen
ähm langweilig wird das andere Sachen
auch andere Republikaner interessanter
sind für sein Wähler jetzt geht es um
dieses Verfahren um diese in diesem
Verfahren um ein Vergehen möglicherweise
viel schwerwiegender ist das was Trump
droht rund um den 6 Januar 2021 als das
Capitol gestürmt wurde was hören sie
denn aus Washington das ist ja in
Washington geschehen ist denn schon
absehbar wann ist da ob es und wenn ja
wann ist zu einem Verfahren kommt ja das
darf natürlich nicht aus dem
Untersuchung rauskommen wann es zu Ende
wird aber noch in Erinnerung zu rufen
der
amerikanische Justizminister hat ein
Sonderermittler berufen der dann nicht
unter seine sogenannten politischen
politischen Kontrolle steht denn wir
wissen ja Justizminister ist ein
politisch gewählte von Joe Biden und da
will man irgendwie keine
Interessenkonflikte Verdacht davon
erwerke also ein Sonderermittler so zwei
Sachen untersuchen die diese Aufstand an
hetzung zu Gewalt versuchen eine
regierungsfunktion zu verhindern ein
paar schwerwiegende Punkte auch eine
dieser anhetzung zu Aufstand ist im
in der amerikanischen
Gesetzgebung ein Grund warum er nicht
kandidieren können normale
Verbrechen okay aber
Aufstand da wäre es dann sozusagen
vorbei übrigens auch bei diesem
Verfahren in New York jetzt sollte Trump
verurteilt werden heißt es nicht dass er
Kandidat werden kann sondern er könnte
weiterhin Kandidat werden richtig genau
das ist es auch wenn es ein
Schwerverbrechen ist ein sogenannter
Fernuni der einzige
Vorwurf wenn er da wirklich auf der
schuldig erklärt wird wo er nicht
kandidieren könnte ist diese an Aufstand
an heizen das kommt aus der bürgerkriegt
sein und und danach als die südstadler
immer noch verdächtig gesehen worden
sind aber es kann man benutzen okay